please be seated everyone
right good evening members and officers
of the council and members of the press
in public I welcome you to this
extraordinary meeting of the council 7th
of October 2019 we have but a single
item of business this evening but
effective deliberation and the the
decision and effective decision-making
should enable a satisfactory outcome to
the best moment of this council this
evening so first of all fire evacuation
procedures if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices of
fire the stairs either through the
security doors to my right or opposite
the lifts in the foyer please do not use
the lift please assemble in Hawley
square on the green officers will assist
you and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the building webcasting of
proceedings the Proceedings of this
meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the Internet
filming of the meeting I would advise
that if filming takes place anyone in
attendance in the public areas may have
their image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
this evening I have one is there anyone
else No so we have one person filming
this evening any member of the public
who objects to the possibility being
filmed may wish to take this opportunity
to leave the meeting but no one has any
filming or recording will not be
permitted for any items of business
where exempt or confidential information
is considered following an exclusion of
present public from the meeting there
are restrictions on the use of mobile
phones would everyone present please
ensure that their mobile phones are
turned to silent and that they are not
used to make or receive phone calls in
the chamber while this meeting is
progress
everyone has presumably are yes
councillor Piper
Thank You mr. German before you begin
the agenda proper I certainly feel safer
having heard the fire instructors on a
serious note I have a point of order mr.
chairman before we hit the agenda proper
for reference it is the Constitution
part for rules of procedure meetings of
the council section one point three
extraordinary meetings extraordinary
meetings can be called a by resolution
of the council be by the chairman of the
Council C by a statutory officer of the
council d by any five members providing
they have duly signed a requisition
specifying the business to be considered
mr. chairman we have an extraordinary
ting on the 10th and it's obvious when
you look at the agenda the meeting shows
a front sheet to introduce the item and
that she names the lead member and the
for supporting signatories and the
outline specifically the business to be
discussed tonight there is no such front
sheet so there is no record of who
called the meeting nor even a record of
the specific business to be discussed I
received an email this morning stating
that the labor group had called the
meeting because they had concerns
concerns I might add that should be
dealt with in the first instance by the
constitutional review Working Party and
the standards committee before being
brought to full Council mr. chairman I
cannot see the concerns of a political
group on the listing Section 1.3 as a
legitimate reason for calling this
meeting so I have two questions and with
your kind permission after they've been
answered perhaps I could be given the
opportunity either to withdraw the point
of order or to finish the point of order
can members please be advised of the
named members who signed the requisition
and called this meeting and can we be
advised of the specific item of business
to be discussed on that letter if the
requisition is available to be viewed
this evening as a duly signed hardcopy
or an electronic copy could it please be
read out for the moment Thank You mr.
chair
thank you very much councillor Piper and
I would turn it first instance to
democratic services to help me on this
issue councillor Piper we intend a short
adjournment in order to get procure the
paperwork and provide members with all
the details and hopefully that will be
to your satisfaction I'm just going to
adjourn the minute just for a few
minutes while we attend to that
members can I call you to order are we
ready
counselor Piper I have before me the
formal request for an extraordinary
council meeting received from councillor
Everett and the reason for it given in
accordance with the council's
Constitution we the undersigned formally
request that the document to which
formed item 13 on the July the 11th 2019
revised if they have not been amended by
the constitutional review working party
and standards to incorporate such
amendments are brought before an
extraordinary meeting of the Council for
consideration and adoption and I have
the five signatories as councillor
everett counselor Steve Albin councillor
Ruth Duckworth councillor Peter Campbell
and councillor Heather Keene Castle
Piper
I'm sorry I may have missed did it say
to discuss issues that have been made by
constitutional review or have not err
says I shall read again in accordance
with the council's Constitution we the
undersigned formally request that the
documents which formed item 13 on July
the 11th 2019 revised if they have been
amended by the constitutional review
Working Party and standards to cook to
incorporate such amendments are brought
before an extraordinary meeting of
Council for consideration and adoption
that is the exact wording councillor
Piper Piper Thank You mr. chairman
that would if it's a really important
meeting a really important word if they
have been amended chairman I'm sure I
don't need to advise you but in fact
constitutional review working party met
and suggested a number of alterations to
the July paper they were to go to a
Standards Committee and then come to
this council
there has been no standards committee
that at least there hasn't been one
that's advertised and available to seek
and so therefore if the specific
business was to discuss the alterations
if they have been made by constitutional
review and they haven't yet been
ratified then I would argue mr. chairman
with great respect that because park for
agenda for extraordinary meeting section
2.3 where it says that we consider the
business set out on the notice for the
meeting it concludes no other business
to be transacted the business to be
discussed related to changes to that
document no such changes have been made
standards committee has not met there
for this meeting I respectfully suggest
mr. chairman should not be held so I
respectfully request that you close this
meeting with no further discussion or
to take place Thank You mr. Jimmy
counselor Piper I hear what you say I
have some de some dispute here as to AXI
whether that is what has been said
I call upon counselor Everett who would
like to make a pointing clarification
yeah I mean I'll make the point of
clarification which is that some the the
letter actually says amendments which
would be made by Constitution Review
Working Party and standards and the end
is important if they've been properly
constituted they could come before
council as they haven't been sustained
as they can't come before council so the
only thing that can come before council
is the document which has been to both
constitution review working party and
standards and was put to Council on July
the 11th for your for your reassurance
councillor Piper it doesn't mean that we
on this side haven't taken account of
the important discussions that took
place at Constitution review working
party as will become apparent as will
become apparent but I believe that this
meeting has been properly called by the
chair and we should proceed with it
Thank You councillor Everett
are we can we proceed further castle
Piper presume you're satisfied with that
explanation no I'm not but it's your
decision with great respect chairman the
business to be discussed has to be
specific and it had no other business is
allowed to be discussed and I'm sorry
but for me that is not specific enough
and I respectfully request you close the
meeting with no further discussion
however councillor Piper it is my
decision as chairman and we will
continue with the meeting moving on to
apologies for absence agenda item 1
apologies have been received from
councillors heart paulmor Ovenden and
scott are there any other apologies for
absence this evening councillor
Braidwood
cancer Crittenden
counselor constant time counselor day
and that seems to be it
thank you very much mendes agenda item
two declarations of interests are there
any declarations of interest this
evening I'll take that as a no agenda
item three I refer you to generate
everything Standing Orders in relation
to staff changes to the Constitution
senior officers employment rules are
principal reason for being here this
evening I call upon the monitoring
officer for introduction Thank You
chairman
to some extent my if your comments have
already been brought forward all out
says this is the report which came to
July Council but withdrawn before
consideration by the council it has
after in accordance with the view
expressed counsel had gone back to the
Constitution review working party they
have partly considered those matters and
we're seeking advice from and the JNC
chief officers on clarification of the
points raised at that Constitution
remove working party so that's where we
are now and they either mentor the
members of Constitution are here before
you for consideration on adoption today
thank you thank you very much indeed
I call upon councillor Everett would you
like to speak on behalf of the business
we have this evening which I would thank
thank you chair and thank you for your
indulgence and thank you to members for
coming out tonight for this extra
meeting which I've I'm sure wasn't the
most welcome invitation from the council
um cancer Everett I've just made a big
mistake
every chairman makes a mistake in a
while and I've made one this evening I
should first of all have moved the
recommendation as set out in the report
to be adopted with the price chairman
pre second I second that mr. chairman
thank you very much indeed
councillor Everett back to you I'm very
sorry my apologies please carry on as if
you hadn't been interrupted or Wendy
started
thank you so as we as we felt I had a
reason for calling this meeting tonight
is because the lack of a lawful adopted
process for disciplinary matters
relating to the statutory officers is
profoundly unsatisfactory and is causing
disquiet inside and outside this council
council began the work to adopt such a
process through the Constitution Review
Working Party in June but when it was
brought to Council in July it became
clear that members were unhappy with one
aspect of it in particular which is the
process of the sifting of allegations
against the secretary officers to
determine whether or not they are
disciplinary matters as defined in the
1993 legislation because it was felt
that it made the statutory officers the
decision-makers on that matter now I'm
only aware of that as a principal
objection to what was brought to Council
it may be that other members of other
things to say but that's what I am aware
when general purposes convened on
September the second members were
revised by an external trainer that if
the council showed urgency in adopting a
lawful process then that had potential
to offer it a level of protection the
process before us tonight has previously
been agreed by both the Constitution
Review Working Party and the standards
committee but we are not asked to
approve the sifting process there is
nothing in the recommendations which
adds the sifting process to the
Constitution which means that if members
have no other objections to bring
forward there's no actual reason why we
can't tonight adopt a lawful process
furthermore at the meeting of the
Constitution review working party on
September 24th members agreed to remove
one paragraph from the flowchart in
appendix three and mr. house made clear
that officers had no objection to it
being removed and that is the paragraph
which relates to the sifting process in
fact the flowchart doesn't form any part
of the recommendations before the
council this evening as it isn't even
referenced there for that reason I don't
believe that we will be amending the
recommendations from the constitutive
you working
if we changed or removed in similarly
paragraph five pot what 5.1 in the
officer report which relates to this
matter does not form part of the
recommendations either we are not asked
to incorporate the officers report into
the council's Constitution what our
investigations have uncovered is that
there is no legal requirement for the
statutory officers to do the sifting
members clearly feel that members should
do the sifting but whatever lawful route
four would be find council needs to find
a way to adopt a lawful process we
cannot continue not to have one and I
accept that there may be further
improvements to the process which has
been brought forward in the future which
are consistent with the JNC model which
we should be following I need to finish
with the only I can my intelligence for
example dividing general purposes into
two subcommittees of five members in
order to make the disciplinary process
more manageable but in general the
process put forward appears to be
acceptable subject to other accept
objections that members may have
accordingly I want to move the following
amendment which does not change the
recommendations which came forward from
constitutional review working party and
standards and I've shared this with the
monitoring officer and it is to add item
H which says that Council expresses its
dissatisfaction with the process set out
a paragraph 5.1 in the report and
advises the constitutional review
working party that he's unable to
support it that the related paragraph in
the first box of the flowchart forming
annex 3 we deleted and request that
constitutional review working party
brings forward a lawful and practical
alternative proposal for sifting
allegations against the statutory
officers that does not involve the
statutory officers being the
decision-makers in that process that's
what I'm moving
I've got a seconder for that please
councillor Campbell do I have any other
speakers move the event yes it's not
it's a it's not technically speaking we
are debating it first of all do you wish
to speak on this matter council camp
kind of sir paper Thank You mr. chairman
the reference in the communication we've
all been set and I'm certainly not
challenging your motives or anything
like that for doing what you are doing
the reference of to annex one is in fact
an x2 to be found on page 21 of the
document that CR WP constitutional
review working party received on the
24th of the 9th 2019 our recommendations
have been made as I mentioned two
standards which has not yet met to
consider them we did ask for a speedy
meeting the reference to appendix 3 top
panel is in fact an X 4 on page 35 of
the same document again the
recommendations which are in fact
different to today's offering have also
been made by constitutional review to
standards who have not yet met to
consider them for example it may be an
oversight but no provision is made in
the insert suggested for complaints made
by members of the public and I believe
that's very important it simply suggests
complaints from members of staff that
we've just had in the amendment of
reference to paragraph 5.1 on page 16 of
annex one but that was missing from the
original recommendation we made import
with recommendations chair following
lengthy discussions and standards have
not yet met I too received the mandatory
training mine was at a later date on the
29th of September and the result of that
training my recollection of it is that
though we do not have a fully compliant
system in place we should not rush into
anything rather we should carefully
consider our responses and follow due
process within this council we were
further advised to get advice from other
indeed the monitoring officer promised
to get independent advice from outside
the area some of us have in the
meanwhile been engaged in collating
advice from different councils around
the country mr. chairman the monitoring
officer's own advice to the
constitutional review working party on
the 24th of September concerning the
document that's been brought forward to
Council this evening was as followed
agenda item number four introduction and
background paragraph 1.2 page 8 this is
quoting the monitoring officer
I felt that council is not the proper
forum for such a detailed consideration
and it was better that the Standing
Orders be brought back to this committee
ie constitutional review working party
rather than risk them not being approved
at Council on that point mr. chairman
the monitoring officer is absolutely
right full council is not the place to
consider such detailed changes and we
must allow new process CR WP has met and
made recommendations the next stop
therefore is standards anything we
approve this evening whatever the motive
is certainly unconstitutional and would
warrant a robust challenge in any
disciplinary proceedings that might
follow
may I please finish mr. Chairman's two
sentences
we simply cannot support this paper
tonight with or without the changes not
least I believe because it would be
irresponsible for us to approve a faulty
document with some sort of vague promise
we put it right later the people of
Thanet deserve much better so I believe
mr. chairman that by continuing this
debate by the possibility that this may
be passed and it's unconstitutional we
would be interfering with our own
processes and legitimate procedures
Thank You general thank you very much
indeed councillor Piper do I have any
other speakers caster Stevens thank you
very much chair and thank if you're with
kasalivich and I have to say item H sin
sounded awfully like an amendment to me
and it was rather word you know God as
far as rising five words down
and and then got no further which in
itself suggests to me that we ought to
have some time to consider this to you
know that it is a big change to what was
put before the constitutional review
Working Party and before standard so in
my opinion it is a big amendment and
actually I thank Chancellor Everett for
pointing out the fact that in this
process that we're supposed to be
adopting there is actually no reference
to the JNC model it is not one of the
recommendations that you're adopting the
very model that we're trying to put in
place so I think for that reason alone
we need to throw this out because it it
is a nonsense we are including even
though we're saying that we express
concerns about references to the
filtering process you know there are
more issues that need to be discussed
thoroughly the monetary officer has
agreed to remove though wording from the
actual disciplinary procedure that is
appendix 3 and only feel that this whole
process has been deeply muddled by
combining the disciplinary procedure
that basically we're trying to adopt you
to the JNC model which has also been
agreed by the Kemp monitoring officers
and yet here we have additional items
that are part of the filtering process I
believe and I share I'm sure they're
labour party our feet I think all
members here share the belief that we
must have a disagree procedure as soon
as possible and I would have a
suggestions how that could be that could
come about but voting this through is
not the way to do it
I suggest that the constitutional review
working party meets as soon as possible
to discuss the very worthy suggestions
made on October the 23rd 24th 25th and
then standards are all due to meet on
the 7th we could then have an
extraordinary council meeting on the
13th of November we will be waiting a
month
have a procedure that we can all agree
on I think that's really important that
we have a procedure we all will agree on
are not rush through for the sake of one
more month we've waited a year this
should have been in in place a year ago
we waited 11 weeks for the
constitutional review Working Party to
be actually a breeder meet there is no
mention this report of the findings of
that meeting for all those reasons
reasons I urge members to the folks
against this motion thank you thank you
very much indeed councillor Steven sir
the monitoring officer would like to
give some clarification at this point
yes V M the provisions of the J and C
are included in the report in that they
are involved in the revised than the
orders are set out in the report so you
don't refer to it they simply adopt
those procedures and they're set out in
the report already so it does include
the gen C procedures thank you thank you
very much indeed
counselor Stevens you just trying to
come back briefly if I can and then then
actually that goes against what we've
said already that we the J and C the
model an accesory appendix 3 isn't
included the monetary officer says it is
included therefore we have been asked to
adopt something that the members don't
agree with thank Alastair Stevens thank
you very much the monitoring also has
get clarification and he is a
professionally recognized man engaged by
the council do I have any other speakers
councillor ever would you like to carry
on with your well yeah I mean just a bit
of clarification and I think councillor
Piper was actually commenting about an
amendment I circulated outside this
meeting which I've not put forward and I
and I understand it there would be some
confusion around there but having taken
further advice I decided not to bring
that that amendment to this council
meeting so I apologize for the fact that
you obviously were expecting us to bring
that but that isn't what we put forward
and just to be clear to members
generally and in counts the Stephens in
particular the labor group has not
proposed any amendments of the council's
Constitution the labor labor group has
not proposed anything
which would change what has been foot
forward in the process what we've asked
is Constitution review working party to
do things and give them the council's
opinion to Constitution review working
party which I will of thought was a good
idea that's our proposal
I accept that if you don't pass the
recommendations as a whole then it
doesn't go forward but I think our view
is and I think the view of all of this
council is that we do not want the
statutory officers to be the
decision-makers in disciplinary
processes about themselves I think
that's very clear we need to find a
lawful and proper way to achieve that
and how we do it I don't really mind but
we need to get on with it
thank you very much counselor for it
I've got countless
Cox pots counselor pots sorry I couldn't
see if Thank You mr. chair I don't think
how we can actually vote on something
until it has gone to standards we we
said it should go to standards and until
it's gone to standards I don't see how
we can take a vote on it
thank you for councillor Potts do I have
any other speakers casalinda Piper Thank
You chair and this document as Steven
said this should have been put in place
a year ago it was before us in July and
taken away because it wasn't fit for
purpose no changes have been made to
that document standards haven't agreed
it and we should not be voting this
through thank you I've got some more
clarification from the monitor officer
the clarification was it wasn't it
wasn't withdrawn President was not fit
for purpose because there was a concern
about a single aspect of it to do with
the filter mechanism
do we have any further speakers on this
counselor barefoot
yeah Thank You chairman um excuse my
voice
virtually gone but there's enough to say
a couple of words I mean it does seem to
me that we're in a position at the
moment where you know this kind of
general agreement on a principle but
disagreement on the ways that we get
there
and quite honestly it does seem to me
that perhaps the best thing is to wait
until were in a position where the whole
thing can come forward having been
through proper process been through
acquisition really working party
approved by standards and incomes for
ratification to this council so
unfortunately I do find myself in this
situation agreeing with councillor Piper
sort of thank you for bring some levity
into this evening a councillor Beauford
I propose to go to a vote now on the
proposal provide by councillor Everett I
have councillor pots again can we have a
recorded vote please
I'm sure we can does does anybody object
to a recorded vote this evening we're
all happy with that right we'll proceed
to a vote members
oh yeah wouldn't afford it out
counselors the monitoring officer will
can now conduct the recorded fold just
like right this is a vote on the
amendment to the original proposal in
moment
capsule open
counsel are a cancer HB counsel Bailey
that's a Bainbridge counts a Jill Bay
furred cats a Robert Bay furred Katla
Boyd counselor Campbell count to the
common cook counselor curry
that's a Dennis cancer Dexter now so
Duckworth gather Everett Gaza Ference
Casa fellows castle game Catholic Ghana
Casa green Casa Gregory counselor
Hopkinson counselor Huxley counsel a
keen cassock up counselor
Pat Moore counter Parsons counselor
Linda Piper castewart Piper counselor
pots counselor pew counsel Roth now sir
Rogers
Casa roper caseros ecchi counsel David
Saunders Casa Maeve Saunders got a
savage against cat's ass Kobe casts a
shrub Kessler Stephens counter Taylor
counts a Tomlinson counter towering got
a white head casts a wing that's a right
Castle Yates
members I have a result and that
amendment has been lost
we now fall back on the substantive
motion do I have any speakers on that I
don't see anyone who wished councillor
Yates sorry councillor Hopkinson got
your name wrong I just wanted to say
that it does seem to me that although
the chambers split on that vote there's
more agreement about the substance of
what we actually want than disagreement
so I do think it's important to assert
that actually we probably do feel
largely the same about what we're trying
to get to I totally do appreciate the
concerns of accounts Department Stevens
I don't personally think that our
amendment did incorporates the concerns
of what we talked about the
constitutional review party which I'm a
member
yeah but I but yeah so I just wanted to
for that to be stated and for that to be
known that actually although the chamber
seems split on that there's actually I
think a fair amount of agreement what we
do actually want to see changed
counselor Piper Thank You chair now that
we're onto the substantive motion can I
please just repeat one paragraph the
advice of the monitoring officer to the
constitutional review working party was
and I quote I felt that the council is
not the proper forum for such detailed
consideration and it was better that the
Standing Orders be brought back to this
committee rather than risk them not
being approved at the council I don't
know that anything has changed since he
wrote that advice and on that point he
is absolutely right full council is not
the place to consider such detail
changes we cannot therefore support
thank you very much indeed councillor
Piper councillor Everett yes thank you
chair we won't be supporting that the
motion as proposed without the amendment
because our point was that it needed to
be made very clear that this council
wants a different process for sifting
allegations and I'm sorry the members
couldn't vote for it
but nevertheless what I would ask
however is that officers bring forward
this process and get on with it as
quickly as possible because we really do
not want to wait until the December
council meeting to have the process
brought back to us I really think it
needs to be expedited and I think all
sides would agree with that
Kaspar River are you actually saying
that you withdrawn your original motion
sorry the amendment yes the amendments
for now
members a little bit of clarification
for me there we're going to have a vote
now proceed to a vote
those in favor those in case of the
motion could I have those counselors
ecchi would you like to say something
brief our story out now we judge our
mind it again can we proceed to a vote
therefore those in favor those against
and that's unanimous thank you very much
indeed members that concludes tonight's
business thank you very much